امضت حليمه ارباب نحو اسبوع انفكات تركت
ديارها في غرب دارفور بالسودان بسبب
انعدام الامن ولجات الى بلده بوروتا
تشاديه الحدوديه لحليمه ثمانيه اطفال
حاضرون معها والدهم قتل خلال اشتباكات
قبليه في غرب دارفور
تنتظر حليمه لفتره طويله للحصول على حصتها
من الماء
وهي لا تتجاوز ثلاثه لترات لكل فرد من
افراد العائله الاف اللاجئين السودانيين
بحاجه الى الخدمات الاساسيه والطارئه وفق
منظمات انسانيه
نوفر هنا 50 الف لتر في اليوم وهذا يعني
ان اللاجئين يستطيعون الحصول على ما بين
لترين وثلاثه لترات في اليوم وما تريده
المفوضيته ورفع هذه الكميه لتصل الى 15
لترا في اليوم للشخص الواحد باعتبارها
كميه مياه لحاله طوارئ
ين السودانيين في ارتفعت من نحو 20 الفا
في الاسبوع الاول للحرب الى نحو 60 الفا
هذه الايام
معظمهم من النساء والاطفال لا تتوقعوا
حليمه ان تعود قريبا الى السودان وبعد
فقدها لمعيلها في الحرب فانها تناشد
المنظمات الانسانيه ان تقدم لها ما يمكنها
من الاستمرار في البقاء هنا في كات تقدر
السلطات عدد من يقيمون هنا من اللاجئين
باكثر من ثلاثين الف شخص
وتؤكد المنظمات الانسانيه
حاجتها الى نقل اللاجئين من هذا الموقع
قبل قطع مياه الامطار للطرق في هذه
المنطقه
وامتلاء هذا الوادي الذي يسكنون فيه
بالماء
فضل عبد الرزاق الجزيره
بروتا شرقيه تشاد الحدود التشاديه
السودانيه